with great power comes great
responsibility and we all have different
powers some natural and some cultivated
over time some of us can play the violin
some of us can run very very fast some
of us can climb up thousand foot tall
buildings without any ropes or anything
at all like complete and utter maniacs
and you could either just do that for
fun or because you have a death wish or
you could do that for a good cause as
Mason deschamp has done raising money
for all sorts of pro-life causes and
crisis pregnancy centers around the
country
making the case for Life by constantly
risking his own Mason thank you so much
for coming on the show
oh thank you Michael you know I I just
have to say this is kind of a dream come
true I've been listening to your episode
uh to your show since episode five and
so you are not only one but if not the
sole reason I became a conservative so I
just have to thank you a lot you've got
to be kidding me wow man I'm so honored
honored clearly uh listen I knew that
you you were a courageous person already
just from uh reading all the stuff
you've been doing uh but I I didn't
realize how you know absolutely
gentlemanly and scholarly you were until
I saw you with the scotch and the cigar
very very great stuff and I'm really
really honored that I've played some
role in uh helping the way that you
think but but now I feel as though I
might bear some responsibility because
you maniac you just go up there and risk
your life constantly I I see here you
have climbed the 1070 foot Salesforce
Tower in San Francisco the 770 foot New
York Times building a two-bedroom
couldn't have just smooshed that
building when you got to the top there
the 560 foot Renaissance Center uh 400
Tower in Detroit and the 840 foot Devon
Tower in Oklahoma City
how and why
yeah you know so I was actually uh I'd
wanted to join the pro-life movement for
a while and get involved somehow but
nothing has quite convicted me until one
morning I was listening to your show and
I heard about the justice for the five
incident and you know of course like
everybody I I went online and I see
these photos of these babies well then I
read an article about uh cesari
santangelo and how the police not only
didn't arrest the Doctor Who had
brutally murdered these babies but
arrested the activist learned handy uh
instead and so I not only felt like it
was something I should do it felt like a
duty like something I was had to do I
felt convicted and so I'm sitting at
home
I'm a poor college rock climber still am
but I'm thinking to myself you know if
politics are Downstream of culture
and I want to change the culture then
the best way to change the culture is to
somehow become a part of it and there
was this guy his name's Alan Robert and
in the 90s he had climbed all of these
buildings around the world and a movie
came out during quarantine about him
it's called my next challenge and I
watched it and I thought you know
I think I can do that I'm a good enough
climber
and so uh you know I started uh planning
this and it was really hard at first
because I knew if I was was going to do
it I was going to have to do it right I
was going to have to raise the money to
get professional photographer so that I
can really put it out there and I
determined that the cost was going to be
around eight thousand dollars so I'd
emailed every pro-life organization
every conservative organization and you
know I was either ignored or denied and
I really I felt like a Nigerian prince
you know I was like I'm gonna climb
skyscrapers and raise all this money but
uh I finally I had asked my boss in the
time I was working construction for a
company called ninth Island woodcrafters
in Las Vegas and we build like cabinets
and stuff like that and custom woodwork
but I was his apprentice and so he's
like a father figure to me and he said
you know Mason
I believe in you and if this is what you
believe in then I'll fund it and so
that's what got it off the ground and so
I bought all these plane tickets to go
to San Francisco then Detroit uh or New
York then Detroit rather and I bought
him a month in advance right and the
morning I wake up to fly to San
Francisco I get a notification on my
phone that the Roe v Wade draft was
leaked and I didn't plan it it was just
this Divine timing that occurred I I
can't explain it but that really blew up
the story wow that does happen you know
these these things sort of come together
it's almost as though Providence exists
you know and and the world is just rich
in symbols that that's a an amazing
story and uh
it's a really beautiful thing in that
you seem to have learned the lesson from
Trump and the kind of trump era which is
that when you want to get things done in
politics you have to shake up the system
a little bit if you just go along if you
are losing if your side is losing and
you just keep playing by all the rules
that all the other people on your team
are playing by you are pretty much
guaranteed to lose you got to shake it
up and I would never have thought okay
the way to reinvigorate the pro-life
movement and to raise money for crisis
pregnancy centers is to climb a bunch of
buildings but that's exactly the sort of
thing that you've got to do you've got
to kind of I don't know throw a wrench
into the machinations of the system such
that people look at you as they have
have looked at you and say oh wow wait
what's going on this kid is climbing a
thousand feet up high in the air to
raise money for what is oh for crisis
pregnancy centers okay you know I'll
give some money to that that if he's
willing to put his life on the line I'm
willing to raise a little bit of money
so then I've got to ask you
you get to the top of these buildings
how do you how do you handle it I know I
I sound like I'm so naive I sound like
I'm probably a chicken but I get up 50
feet in the air and I start feeling a
little weird okay I get if I'm if I'm up
walking going for a hike and I see a big
drop I I get just this visceral reaction
are you just missing that Gene
uh no I don't think so
um
you know the climbing on on buildings is
a lot easier than on Rock like on Rock
I'm gripping holes the size of credit
cards we're on the buildings I'm able to
stick my hands all the way around it so
I I never feel like I'm gonna fall at
all but if I were to describe what
climbing skyscrapers feels like uh
taking the the technical aspect of
climbing out of it you know you have
police cars everywhere you have
helicopters uh circling around I think I
counted one time I had five news
helicopters filming me and I like to say
it feels like playing the game Grand
Theft Auto but in real life it's so
strange and honestly like I get so
nervous before I go climb these
buildings but it's it's not from the
climbing it's from the the security and
and all of the the other things that go
with it but you know when I get to the
top of these buildings
it's so funny that the police they're
never mad at me they're always really
impressed and and so uh you know I've
never really treated like a a criminal
they'll throw me in the police car all
angrily for the for the news cameras but
we get back to the police station and
you know they're coming down to take
selfies with me and and I'm signing
autographs with my hands behind my back
and I say it's pretty hard at first but
you do enough of them you get pretty
good at it and the funniest moment was
one time uh you know I was like
I kind of want some coffee right now
that'd be really nice and they came and
they brought me some coffee and so I've
never treated like a criminal
um but you know I get criticized a lot
because when I do this I am arrested
it's it's not actually illegal like in
Detroit it's so funny there's a law that
says you cannot lease your pet alligator
to a fire hydrant but there's no law
that says you can't climb the
Renaissance Center and the way
trespassing laws work they're able to
arrest me and then eventually it all
just gets dropped because there's
there's no way to really prosecute it
they just want to make an example so
that no one goes and repeats it which I
think is fair but uh you know you're
reminding me of Just The Perils of big
government taking away all of those
simple joys in life like a man trying to
leash his alligator to a fire hydrant
here come the Liberals yet again to
quash that sort of Joy it's funny you
mentioned this though because I I would
imagine it requires it would least
require in me some concentration to
climb up a thousand foot skyscraper
maybe you it's a little bit more second
nature but you would think if these cops
and everybody want to make sure that
you're safe and don't fall they wouldn't
just start grazing you with helicopters
Sirens everywhere seems like that might
be a little distracting uh yeah it's a
little bit distracting but it's a part
of it you know like one of the things I
learned when I started doing activism is
you know you really have to focus your
activism on gaining this sort of media
attention and learn how the media works
because if you only reach the people
that are there it's not as effective and
you don't reach the people of the world
of course of course that's so true I
mean this is true in any political
system but especially in one that is
notionally self-governing
it's all about the media this is why the
libs have taken such efforts to control
the media specifically to control the
narrative on pro-life activism
so then I got asked two questions going
way back
and you know this was not a setup I had
no idea that you listened to my show I'm
very honored that that I could have
played some role in this but how did you
become pro-life was it just the cesare
sent Angela story or was were there
inklings of pro-life activism before
that and then how did you get into
climbing at all
yeah you know I I grew up Catholic so I
I was just around other pro-life people
I hadn't you know cemented those ideas
in my head but listening to people like
you Ben Shapiro Stephen Crowder you know
you just hear the arguments on the side
of life and they're really hard to
debate against they are just so concrete
I mean a baby in the womb is a life that
is separate from the mother it has its
own DNA from conception if you go and
dig up bodies at a mass grave site you
can tell the difference between these
bodies based off of their DNA it's the
most like I guess basic separation
between people of course it's funny
because
digging up grave sites also pokes a hole
in the transgender argument you'll see a
forensic investigators they'll say okay
we found the body
of a woman
and and the reaction to that would of
course be oh yeah how do you know she's
a woman how do you know did you ask her
no how did you know hold on so I can
know that a cadaver was a woman but I
can't know that a lady walking around
his woman doesn't make a whole lot of
sense and obviously this is all the more
true for the pro-life cause obviously
and if you talk to an abortion Advocate
who's willing to be candid and honest
with you they will admit they will say
yes the baby is living has all the
characteristics of life yes the baby is
an individual it's not not a fingernail
not just a kind of cancerous tumor on
the mother yes that's true and they'll
usually give the argument if you're if
you catch them in a candid way and
they're they're not afraid of admitting
things on camera they'll give the
argument that Naomi wolf gave in the 90s
which is
the baby is a baby the baby is alive and
for women to have equal feminist
political rights that the mother needs
to be able to murder her child and all
of his Humanity which is ghastly but at
least that's what they're saying right
and that's why they can't say that
publicly very often is because people
would recoil from it the reality of it
is so obvious for anyone who's willing
to look at it yeah you know and that's
why you know I do what I do I think the
with the reality of abortion we should
do everything in our peaceful means to
to stop this and sort of regardless of
of the consequences like I get
criticized a lot like Romans 13 Romans
13 but you know you look at where Romans
was written and not only who wrote it uh
Romans was written I believe in a jail
cell by Paul who was later beheaded for
crimes against the state and so I I
think again like we should do everything
within our peaceful means to stop this
evil that's going on and
you know I uh I like to tell jail
stories they're kind of fun
please I hope you're not beheaded for
them but please uh oh no how's it been
no it's so funny like jail was really
scary at first and I when I got arrested
in Detroit they were taking me back into
uh the holding cell
and this is a dirty jail it's it's I
mean Detroit it's it's so already
impacted let alone defunded uh after
black lives matter and so this this jail
is just you know a scary place and they
walked me back in the cell and you've
got the Crips on one side and the
blood's on the other so it's like Crips
Bloods pro-life Spider-Man you know in
his mother's day so I climbed the
Renaissance Center on Mother's Day so if
you're in jail on Mother's Day you are a
real criminal you know these guys and
they have teardrops and ice cream cones
tattooed on their face they've been
there before
and I'm walking in there and I'm
thinking like what did these guys do to
get in here and it's so funny because
they were thinking like what did this
white kid do to get in you know this is
this is actually the plot of Alice's
Restaurant I don't know if you know the
old Arlo Guthrie song but it's this guy
who gets arrested for littering and then
he ends up at the draft board the whole
thing is you know I was sitting there on
the bench with all these criminals we
got mother rapers and father stabbers
and father rapers and there was me they
said kid what are you in for I said
littering and that's basically what
you're putting in for I climbed a
building uh what
yeah and that's the funny thing is like
they're all wondering what I did and as
soon as I tell them you know all the
gang beef just goes right out the window
and they're laughing and they're asking
me questions and so I like to tell
people that I'm one of the the few men
to ever bring the Crips and the blood
together even if it was just for a
moment in jail but my my favorite jail
story
was from Oklahoma City I was in Oklahoma
county jail and whenever I go I like to
evangelize again like looking at people
like Paul in the Bible they they uh they
get arrested and put in prison and they
say I'm going to grow my Ministry and so
that's what I I try to do in jail and I
I tell them you know why I'm in there
and why I'm doing it and one of the guys
he actually told me
he said uh his girlfriend was pregnant
and what he didn't tell me was that they
were planning to have an abortion
and about a week went by and Nathan
burning the CEO of let them live the the
charity I raised money for calls me on
the phone and he says hey man I just got
a phone call from a woman who said that
their boyfriend met you in Oklahoma
county jail and they want to choose life
and so you know it was again like this
Divine timing like it what I do is such
a farce you know like climbing buildings
it's just so silly it's pretty cool it's
this mechanism that I've used to be able
to make a difference in this movement
and
I just feel blessed honestly that uh you
know I'm able to be the vessel for the
Lord's work with something so silly as
climbing buildings that's that's amazing
because wow you think for most people in
their lives
if that's all they ever did
if that's all you ever did in your whole
life was you sat in jail with this guy
and convinced him not to kill his kid
that would be a life well lived like you
would have done it you would have
accomplished more in your life than
pretty much anybody
and how many of those stories are there
and and and and it's inspirational in
the sense that we can do that too I
can't climb a building I I can barely
climb to the top of my ladder to change
a light bulb on the second floor of my
house but but what can we do you know
you it's not just big stunts that do
these sorts of things in your quotidian
experience when you're just sort of
having lunch with somebody
if you can just plant that kind of seed
obviously you could never have planned
it to say I'm going to get arrested to
go to the Detroit jail on this day so
that I can talk to this guy so he can
tell his girlfriend not to have an
abortion but but it happened and now you
know God willing pregnancy goes well and
everything there's going to be a human
being who can come up and say hey thanks
man thanks for convincing my dad not to
kill me
yeah you know I uh that was part of I
guess the messaging and and when I
started this project it was you know you
guys can't all climb skyscrapers but you
can go out and do something and I I tell
people on every interview I do I say I
get called a radical but the most
radical thing you can do in the pro-life
movement is do nothing so I hope that
people can look at what I do and and be
inspired and go out and and do something
because abortion is
you know the evil that all evil is
standing on
of course I mean you think of
of radicals you know at the time of say
chattel slavery or something like that
and at the time the people who say hey
maybe we should you know kind of unwind
this institution here you know kind of
get rid of this whole thing you know
they would have been called radicals but
now with the the
with hindsight you look and you say no
it's the people denying Humanity to a
large number of people they they would
seem to be much much more radical and so
a question then becomes what what are
people going to say about us you know
there is there is no neutrality there's
no middle ground here between do we kill
850 000 babies a year or do we not kill
I guess the middle ground is we kill 400
000 babies a year but that's not much of
a middle ground you know King Solomon
talked about this too uh so uh you know
which side are you going to be on if you
throw your hands up in the air you
you've made a decision if you just sort
of allow this sort of thing to happen
without any pushback at all you you have
absolutely made made a decision can I
ask for well I want to ask two things
before I let you go one
and I asked you this a little bit
earlier but we got off track how did you
learn to climb I mean how did you start
you know you're pretty young man right
now when did this start yeah this
started in high school I uh grew up in
Michigan hunting and fishing and you
know I was outside every day and then uh
my dad he was a carpenter and it just
got hard on his body doing construction
so we moved to LA and California the
hunting's just so much different than
Michigan so I needed something else
outdoorsy to do so uh my dad he he
bought me a rope some quick draws and a
harness and I learned how to rock climb
off of YouTube and we would go out on
the weekends maybe once a month and go
rock climbing but when I graduated high
school I actually skipped my graduation
and I moved to Yosemite and that was
where you know Yosemite Valley is just
the gauntlet it is the mecca of rock
climbing so that's where I really got my
feet wet and uh you know
it's so crazy I never thought I'd be
climbing skyscrapers uh or like the
other day someone approached me and they
want to make a comic book out of me and
I'm like I never in my life did I ever
think I would have my own comic book but
here I am and I'm so grateful that
everyone is supporting me and and uh you
know donating money to let them live.org
I think it's just absolutely fabulous a
total inspiration everybody should go
check out
letthelive.org everybody should keep up
with Mason's work obviously and I want
the comic book when can I go buy this
comic book
you know it's a work in progress It's a
hard thing to make a comic book about
abortion so we're trying to work out a
way to do it
we're maybe going for Johnny The Walrus
yeah kind of kind of angle you know like
like make it about abortion but not yeah
with a lighter touch but I I agree that
it is tough it is tough to make a
cartoon or or a a comic book about it
but listen you've done harder things
okay you've climbed a thousand foot
building all right so so uh I I have no
doubt that it will happen Mason
incredible work really keep it up just
so inspirational and everybody go keep
up with Mason descham the pro-life
Spider-Man thank you Michael
foreign
[Music]
[Music]